thank you I already won I work for not
on the I street dot-com in London I'll
talk about that later you can find the
slides online unless in case you and
I'll see them but you seem to be pretty
visible so this is a talk about how to
make your Python code run faster why do
we care about speed because we live in
the age of low attention span I have a
low attention span of maybe 20 seconds
Linda morning then it just goes down a
bit and since we want results fast I'm
going to tell you that we are going to
build up to this stable
the magic table of not so slow anymore
it is not the whole truth but it's not
fully eristic why does our program run
slow why slow because these machines
have limited resources they have some
CPU some memories Ram disk and they are
not infinite so arm programs when we use
all of one resource we go slow for
example when we use all of our CPU the
instructions just queue up and you go
slow if you use all of your memory as
this helpful example shows you get an
out of memory error and the operating
system kills your process there also
happens a bit if you use up all of your
disk so you can you can rent it out of
this can you get like this disk full
error a much more frequent problem is
using up all of
or bandwidth so basically you're writing
as fast as you can or you're reading as
fast as you can do you really need to
wait for reading and writing something
you really need to say okay I write I
write that file in phone because when
you're waiting you're blocking and the
flow of the program doesn't go through
network is even slower especially if you
use all of your bandwidth and again do
you need to wait for the response I know
you probably don't even know what the
API on the other end is doing so I have
to tell why you're going slow well you
could log I mean that's helpful
sometimes it's all vital to know what
your program is doing and if you really
really need to know what your program is
doing the best thing is to profile it as
you know there's also a cheating easy
way just use a system monitor my
favorite is H dot and it's not going to
always work but you can see how much CPU
is using much memory anomaly how much
disk and once you know why your program
is slow well what you can do there are a
few kind of solutions you can paralyze
it so you you can use credit processes
you can use a sink - you two have
concurrency you can use an alternative
interpreter like pi PI or you can push
the C and we'll see cycling there so
once again the magic table of not so
slow anymore and you see there's like
different colors some are bigger wings
some are decent wings and some are no
principal waiting well if you can run
multiple operations at the same time it
means you don't need to wait well the
program will go on and do something and
then one piece of the program is waiting
the idea of concurrency is basically you
can run multiple operations at the same
time the idea of parallelism at least
for the duration of this talk is you can
run as many of the same operation as you
want at the same time and if you can run
more than one thing at the same time
what you don't have to wait an example
of a parallel task
I'll ask Python where to find some
things I care about and it asks the
Google Maps API and for this thing we I
don't need to wait because I don't need
to know we're barely nice glow to know
where laundry is and I might have more
problems with other things on that list
classical sequential tasks I need to
know previews outputs to get the
subsequent outputs Fibonacci numbers
the first way to avoid waiting is to use
threads ideally if you can paralyze you
just import the thread pool map your
inputs through your operations and you
get outputs in reality sometime you just
need to create it straight manually
overwrite the run command and and then
start them and the fact that I didn't
see everybody seeing my notes
ah classy other thread works the are any
independent part of the program Brett
just goes on the implementation sometime
depends on the operating system it's
part of the program shares memory we
with the Kolar with the main thread and
they also share interpreter the Python
interpreter so you have limitations
memory shared if I want to write in the
same memory location I need to manually
synchronize and if you have ever used
locks well you know the Armas also the
share interpreter as a performance
overhead so you encounter something
called the global interpreter lock and
basically have only one interpreter that
you can use the threads are very useful
when threads are kind of useful for
Network and disk because you didn't have
to wait on Io they are not really
helpful if you are running out of CPU or
you're running out of memory processes
are sort of the bigger cousins of
threads so you can use them to avoid
waiting on disk and network and also you
can you use them to use all the CPUs on
your machine rather than just one
I'll do the work while they spawn a new
Python interpreter which is a new
operating system process how do they
spawn it again implementation depends
some time it's for some time it's it
will serialize the input with pickle
limitations while explaining a new
process in the operating system is
putting the new interpreter you have a
startup time if the memory footprint of
the interpreter and you cannot share
memory well actually you can safely
share memory if you use these libraries
things to watch out for while using
processes make your coding portable
otherwise you're going to execute it
every time and avoid shared stateful
objects like the B connections big wins
you get you can use all of the CPUs
because the operating system will
allocate one CPU to each new process and
then spool shuffle them around like they
like they work different programs on
your computer all of these concurrent
operations in time well they are really
good place to create a framework so
someone created the framework called
salary concept of salary is you have
many workers you can manage them you
have a shared task queue a framework is
more power simple of life except at the
beginning when you need to learn how to
use the framework the big take out of
salaries you can use multiple machines
because sqs or readies we will
communicate between machines so they're
based on the network so you can spawn
your tasks to several different machines
I think the not so new anymore or new
thing that there is to be a synchronous
processing in order libraries like
Toronado and twisted and now it's part
of python free how does a sync work if
you ever programmed a video game maybe
just something simple with a with PI
game you know there is an event loop and
you wait for the users to give you some
commands and then you update the state
of the game whenever the user does
something I think works in a very
similar way you have an event loop and
you touch some tasks to it this tests
are called coroutines the loop checks
each go routine for new event if there
is something oh there is a new event so
I react to that event I'll execute some
code maybe a return value or maybe I'll
go to a place where I need to wait for
another event and that those places are
signaled by the await instruction and
the curtain is identified by that a sync
instruction while when the loop finishes
checking one instruction while it moves
on to the next one the benefit is you
can handle much more concurrent things
that you do then with threads we threads
you're sort of limited to how many you
can spawn on a loop you can attach a lot
of tasks this makes it ideal for network
limited things so if you're calling the
API is probably you want to be using I
think if you are developing a web server
you definitely need to be using a sync
so most of the modern web servers are
actually using a version of a sink maybe
not in Python but a similar programming
construct
limitations well you cannot use requests
so if I if I'd have to implement that
example I at the beginning where what I
look up things on the Google Maps API I
couldn't use request I will need to use
a I your HTTP there's like actually an
example if you guys are interested in
you need to explicitly handle exceptions
otherwise your stuff might just die and
you don't get any input and if you want
to limit how much how many concurrency
concurrent tasks can run at the same
time you need to use semaphores so I
think really useful for disk and network
applications okay what if I really need
to I'm really limited by CPU running
goal with all the processors in my
machine doesn't work well I could type I
PI I can use it instead of calling
Python simply installed and it's very
attractive because I may not need to
change my code at all
so I may not need to change any line in
my code how does it work
it's an interpreter itself is written in
our Python so restricted byte and this
allows it to decide whether it needs to
combine your instructions on the fly or
not this is called just-in-time
computation so the interpreter can
decide okay this instruction has been
running several times
I'll just compile it this instruction
has me running just once
it just goes interpreted the biggest
benefits are for long running processes
obviously because then being interpreted
as this time to actually gather the
statistics and do it
limitations just Python to the Python
freezing better not all libraries will
work and I'm sure you are aware that if
you want to use numpy with pi PI you
need to use a specific number fork
maintained by the PI by community please
for now sometime you will need to tune
the parameters so you will need to turn
the garbage collection in pi PI and the
RAM usage is very successful very
sensible to this tuning so you might end
up using less Ram then not running
important you might end up using a lot
more RAM than running in Python
depending on how you tune the Python
interpreter and this is why there are
two those two exclamative marks it can
go either way you could get a bitter a
bit of run back you could end up using a
lot more ram but it's definitely a
winner
in terms of CPU well what if I you just
want to win well you could push your
execution to see there are suspensions
you just compiled the slowest part of
your program but it means rewriting at
least some parts of a program in C what
can you do you can use seitan which is a
lighter weight solution if you install
it you call it with seitan it has
support for paralyzing operations you
define a function as a sytem function as
CDF or as a site on n function with a p
with the Python wrappers with CP def you
are some static types and then you're
ready to go and you can get quite a huge
speed up
so once again the magic table of knots
or so anymore so I'm going to solve all
your problems all the time but if you
really don't know where to start maybe
this can help you thank you any
questions anyone height thanks very much
for your talk
Easter so on your like magic table of
not so slow anymore there's well rum has
lots of axes so if I really care about
optimizing rum usage without trading off
too much CPU or disk and network what
would be the best solution running on if
your bottleneck is around probably you
are in a good place so you probably
don't if you are running out of RAM then
you're probably in a bad place because
your code is crashing but if you're if
your problem is you cannot read and
write fast enough from when from ROM and
you're probably in as good a place as
you can be unless you're like reading
and writing a lot of stuff that you
don't need to to do then you can maybe
think about like okay am i doing the
right operations am I using the right
algorithm
hi thanks for your talk on the
asynchronous front do you have a
preferred third-party library so the OD
async are your stuff in the standard
library is pretty low-level it's not
really meant to be used kind of as such
but it's more as a building block for
people do you have a preference I tend
to use it this is the full example this
is what I would use it so if you have
any good suggestion for libraries I
could use to make this code fit in a
slide I will be so grateful
I've seen people suggest kurios someone
someone yesterday also said trio I was
wondering if you tried those and if
they're any improvement so my main pain
point is taking this from here suppose
you're gradually migrating to an
asynchronous project so I'm working on
something that's quite big it's making a
lot of HTTP requests through a request
so that's all blocking in synchronous
and now we're gradually starting to
migrate and you find yourself having to
go up the call stack and make everything
async the moment you replace one call
everything that calls that function all
the way up to the main method needs to
be needs to become asynchronous and that
breaks your program because there's a
ton of scripts that call things I guess
that's partly because of that design and
using something as a library and as a
standalone thing but you eventually find
out that the moment you make one thing
asynchronous yes it has to go all the
way and then everything just breaks so
this is a very common problem with a
with a synchronous see you can probably
find it in other languages as well but
once you you decide to that you want an
event loop well that's your main thread
of execution
the only sorry can you pick and choose
like well I want an event loop er and
then I want a normal contour flowing in
another place and okay thank you
we as Python developers just said it's a
drum problem and also this yield instead
of return there's a lot of memory and
also a lot of your I think general
malicious use generators and DiMaggio is
actually also using generators as our
core teams so that you can step by step
go to a parallel world without the event
loop but Ram if you run out of RAM check
replace your returns by years it says a
lot yes
DRN experience extending Python with
rust do you have that experience no not
really but I was wondering if ties that
works well or not
well definitely threads don't have the
same meaning that they have in other
languages I think yeah not sure every
language is sort of unique it is like
its own unique history of how it came to
be alright thank you very much thank you
[Applause]